towards the end of January last month I
was invited to massive entertainment in
Malmo Sweden while there we spoke about
and played through some of the division
2 year 2 content now I could quite
easily spend the next 30 minutes talking
about how much I love the city of Malmo
and the country in general but I'm
pretty sure that's not why you're here
so over the next couple of days I'll be
releasing videos on what was shown to us
and giving my feedback on what I saw and
experienced this first video if you
hadn't already guessed it by now is
going to be centered around the
progression of the story both in episode
3 and year 2 once I've run through this
I'll share a few theories of my own to
fill the gaps and to highlight where I
think the story is going
[Music]
[Music]
the trailer for Episode three was
actually released twelve in Sweden and
I'll be honest it was pretty hard enough
to jump on board with the rest of the
community and discuss what we saw and
thought we saw however I didn't want to
get too carried away and break one of
the multiple India's had signed now I
know this has been out for a couple of
weeks but I did want to briefly run
through the trailer before talking about
year two to hopefully help give some
perspective as to what we're likely to
see coming up it's been talked about for
quite a while now and it's great to see
from the episode three trailers that yes
we're finally going back to New York or
Coney Island to be more specific eight
months have passed since we were last in
New York and now we're heading back to
find the scientist who was a colleague
and friend of dr. Gordon Amherst the
Talley trinka we've all been looking for
a cure since the virus first hurt and he
could be the answer it has been months
since Vitaly was kidnapped by Aaron Tina
and now it would appear that the black
tusk heaven as the hostage he is heavily
guarded and this could be a trap but
this could also be the only opportunity
that we get and the division has thrown
all caution into the wind enact
immediately it is during the assault on
the black tusk at Luna Park on Coney
Island that the division is met with a
familiar foe the cleaners are back
except this time there is something very
different about them if sub-3 introduces
us to two new missions Coney Island
newsmen Park and Coney Island ballpark
release date well pretty much now
following on from the missions in
Episode three were introduced to the
year two content eight months after the
events of New York City we're returning
to New York the good news were not just
here for a couple of missions in fact
we're actually going to be given a whole
new open world that will be a
representation of lower Manhattan the
area just under the location of where
division 1 took place the snow has
melted away but a recent hurricane has
devastated the landscape year two is
continuing the narrative side of the
game which obviously I'm quite happy
about
we episode 3 is about rescuing Vitaly
from the hands of the black tusk in the
air - were on the hunt for Aaron Kino
Kira is supported by a legion of rogue
agents including four lieutenants who
are part of his trusted inner circle
these lieutenants have access to a wide
range of new skills and technology and
should be approached with caution on top
of us
Keenan now has a new weaponized
variation of the virus at his disposal
Aaron has sworn to destroy everything
that the division stands for and put a
stop to what they're trying to achieve
as he states that everything they're
doing is just repeating the mistakes
that have led us to the situation that
the world is currently facing he goes on
to inform that what has been happening
is bigger than any one of us in year two
we'll be seeing the return of a number
of characters from the division one like
fail ow and port Rhodes no word on rip
the lessee right now but fingers crossed
people as we've seen will be coming up
against a new and improved force of
cleanness but also the records we'll be
making a return in both instances their
original leaders in supporting
commanders have long been taken care of
so it's any one guess as to who's
calling the shots and what their
objectives are
warlords of New York will bring us four
new names owns five main missions and
eight side missions the missions can be
played in any order and the side
missions are directly linked to specific
main missions based on what I've got to
try out it looks like each mission is
linked to one of kinas lieutenants upon
defeating each lieutenant you unlock the
unique skill they're using these sort of
meteor events can almost be a little
painful at times that give you just
enough information to spark interest and
right as you're really starting to get
into it the information stops leaving
your hanging wanting more obviously
that's the whole idea and it would be
pretty lame if they were to divulge the
entire story before it was even released
but because this is what I do I'm gonna
speculate in an attempt to fill in some
of the gaps let's start with the episode
three trailer here we see division
agents landing on Coney Island at Luna
Park or solar park as it seems to be
called in game he isn't named but the
man in the box is very obviously vitally
training Co we see during the fighting
that the black test two are taking
surprise by a group of cleanest that
made the way into the compound something
that isn't shown in the video is that
the cleaners seem to have access to a
range of new chick like drones
it isn't clear who's been supplying them
but they certainly don't seem to be
working alongside the black tusk in the
final scene we see an agent walking away
from a more senior looking black cast
member it doesn't look super red but it
does look to be representing a rogue
agent and if this is the case it's
highly likely to be Erin keener with the
black task officer potentially being the
leader of the black tasks specialist
unit Barton Schaffer but it could easily
be one of the other remaining black task
officers like Elijah Sumner or Jack
Bonnie
however it's entirely possible that
these two people are out for oxen and
main tasks from the broken door book but
I find this list likely as these are
completely unknown in-game so they'd
have to introduce a lot more story to
explain who these people are and given
the build-up to episode three over the
last few months revolving around Erin
kita
I see this as being the more likely
scenario
so if that in mind the questions are
head from this are white did Aaron kina
hand over his biggest trump card
Natalia anchor and who is leading the
cleaners and Rutgers and how do they get
the hands on this new tech firstly let's
look at the cleaners and wreckers I feel
like we're dealing with another hyenas
situation here
they've been supplied with weapons and
gadgets from an anonymous source the
source bring the black tusk the reasons
for doing this much the same as with the
hyenas in DC to create chaos and keep
what remains of the government troops
busy anything that would distract the
division from the black tasks carrying
out their plans but what I think has
happened here is the cleaners have
become more organized than they expected
and encroached on their operation on
Coney Island unexpectedly as far as kina
goes and why would it ever hand over the
telly no I don't think he's working for
the black tusk but he could be working
with them however not to help them
achieve their goals
I'll explain I feel that Keener's gifted
vitally to the black tusk in order to
get something that he needs in this case
gear technology and Intel as we can see
the keenest lieutenants are sporting
gear beyond what the division agents
have used up until this point but is
that worth giving up vitally Fortis
after all he's the closest thing alive
to the creator of the doll flow he is
the answer and the potential creator of
anything that could supersede the virus
that has crippled the country if I'd
only seen the episode 3 trailer I'd say
no it's not worth it but since we now
know that Aaron Keena has his own
variation of the virus thanks to his
time of halting opted for tele as as
hostage perhaps he doesn't need him
anymore or maybe he's planning to take
him back at some stage while the black
tusk is busy with the division Aaron
keener is the smartest man in the room
or at least he thinks he is and he's
only but proved this is actually the
case time and time again since he
defected from the division he is always
being two steps ahead of what's been
going on and it's unlikely what's been
happening right now is going to be any
different he was right about the powers
above the trade the division in the
United States and there is no way that
he would form an alliance with the force
let the black tusk or whoever's behind
them
he's smart enough to realize the type of
people who are working for and that
they're likely in some way responsible
for the event that made him decide to go
rogue in the first place the black task
of the type of people that Kenan warned
us about long before we came in contact
with them the only thing that really has
me puzzled
is wipe the black tusk live for Taylor's
rudenko in this open section of the park
why haven't they moved him on it all
feels like a little bit of a trap to me
[Music]
obviously that last part was just me
throwing around ideas in fact by the
time I can upload this it will be the
release date for episode 3 so some of it
will already have been confirmed all
proven wrong the objective of this video
was to share what I had learnt about the
law and story in year two while it mess
of studio I'm pretty stoked with the
narrative continuing this way but if
you'd like to see what we were told and
how I feel about the upcoming
improvements in in-game content I'll
have another video coming out in the
next day or so
I must thank you be soft anz and the
massive team for looking after me well
as over there two things I learned one
the NX beard is even more beautiful in
person
I'd love to know how he maintains they
at least and two I'm starting to believe
that Hamish is a myth I spent two full
days of massive in the last 12 months
and I'm a behemoth of a man I can't be
missed I'm thinking that he's just an
elaborate made-up character to be the
face of the state of the game in the
division in general possibly using some
sort of projection technology developed
by scale tech I don't know I'm totally
just starting rumors about Hamish being
some sort of AI now next time dude stop
hiding from me anyway I hope you guys
found this interesting and I'll catch in
the next one Cheers
[Music]
you